in a world of typecast there are worse
things to be typecast as than the 60
year old badass in a world of typecast I
think Liam Neeson has won that the
Commuter so non-stop tear it's not
really nonstop to the commuter stars
Liam Neeson he's a family man he's down
on his luck he's on the train he takes
every day then Vera Farmiga comes to him
and says hey we want you to do this
thing here's some money do you want to
find this person we want you to find it
soon realizes he's in over his head but
that's basically the movies he has to
find this person on this train yes so
much time to do it just investigating
and deductive reasoning you need to
narrow it down to this one person it's
kind of the movie but it's not the whole
picture
movie tries to venture out because you
can tell it like people are gonna start
to get claustrophobic within the train
this entire movie lets little sad things
happen and when these things happen
especially the last act of the movie
it's so out of place it feels like the
movie doesn't mix in the world of Liam
Neeson being Liam Neeson I think Liam
Neeson is the only Liam Neeson who can
actually play Liam Neeson as well as the
Liam Neeson plays Liam Neeson it's G
what I'm saying here movie itself falls
short but there's something morbidly
entertaining about watching Liam Neeson
be this character couple of scenes I
genuinely liked a couple of scenes of
tension where I was white knuckling
gripping my seat does admit this is
remarkably intense for a movie that's
just not remarkably great so props to
that there is this fight sequence that
does the weird camera zooming digitally
around everyone's head green-screen
things first time I noticed it was
Kingsman the Secret Service when he's in
that epic shootout in that church not
I'm gonna shoot out it's a massacre this
is crazy and then Kingsman - did it I
was like I'm kind of wise to the act now
and I could totally tell us on a green
screen this movie does it while Kingsman
the Secret Service I felt did it best he
will need to either refine that or stop
using it because it really takes me out
of it when two people are fighting and
they're moving weirdly unnatural like
they're out of Silent Hill and like in
fact is the commuter is a more boring
version of non-stop that's right it's
the star of non-stop it is the same
director as non-stop it's the same basic
premise of non-stop but it's not a
sequel to non-stop fact is as
entertaining as this movie looked like
it was going to be as much as I actually
ended up liking the set up it was edited
very weird and jarring but the prologue
to the movie just kind of shows how this
guy is a normal everyday guy going about
his day to day it was great setup and
then from there the movie just kind of
bores you cuz he is lost for 90% of this
movie then he kind of gets it in his
head like alright here's how I'm gonna
find this person then he does it and
then there's something that happens
after that in the movie and for a lot of
movie he doesn't gain any ground which
makes you just kind of check your watch
like alright let's go this one
should have filtered through a few
different people so they can refine
those points but we're finding those
points I think would be more than just
refining that one point making that one
tweak really does change the entire
movie you have to have a whole new
situation for these moments but you
can't do that I mean you can do that but
obviously they were like look we don't
have time this is a January movie come
on guys in the end any way you slice it
you have seen the premise of the
commuter before maybe a little different
it may be a lot the same but the point
is you've seen it I'm not gonna really
remember this movie in fact I'm not
gonna remember the commuter in t-minus
one day under can drop as far as January
movies go this isn't actually the most
painful I've ever had it back it's not
painful at all it's just not that
memorable all right guys so not nonstop
- have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]